thank you
[Music]
welcome everybody to another strange
episode of JK news where we're going to
receive an announcement at the same time
you guys special enough
announcement time whoa okay
so uh God dang it YouTube's screwing us
again the thing is uh you know we talked
about this in a different OTR but also
everyone who has a channel that cusses
is getting all their videos demonetized
no you might say they're getting effed
with
they're getting fricked with yeah yeah
gosh darn it shoot and this happened
overnight like yeah nobody I mean right
after New Year's two was like happy New
Year and guess what almost all of your
videos just not gonna have ads anymore
and we know that we're already dangling
on the edges of a cliff and that we have
our hands up here and there's a boot
being kicked on our freaking hands but
this is our plea for help and so
um
this is the JK Telethon guys the villain
is like
and then peeling back one finger I'm
like oh we got two fingers left you
really need this job or the hang in
there kitten so basically we just we
just you know did a 40 pay cup and maybe
maybe another 40 but you know um We're
Not Gonna count another 40 because 340s
just go over 100 but that leaves us with
20 pay which is
the rooftop let's go but you just said
so this is demonetized
you double down on it so can do your
thing
so last time we did a patreon we were on
life support and that was because the
it was it was adpocalypse it was pretty
it was pretty wild and then after a
while you know we we gained some
traction and it was great again and here
comes YouTube with the big Rod of a
boner just boning the living life of JK
again right when we get up what do they
do 300 kick us in the stomach right into
the cave and say this is YouTube
and so we had to come up YouTube came at
us like this
and we went down the ground with them we
shouldn't we shouldn't and we shouldn't
we shouldn't have and we learned they're
pulling guard and we learned they pull
guard yeah guard pullers also back then
respectfully we are [__] we are being
[__] because the time was forcing us
you're right and so like when you're on
patreon you're like cool they're still
[__] that's awesome like so but now
we're kind of back we're kind of like we
found our voice again attitude Arabic
but you're right though because it was a
really dangerous time for like being
canceled so a lot of our cancel maybe I
don't know I'm scared went to patreon I
said shut up can we put that on patreon
but yeah so like I want to give value to
the people that are still on patreon and
also if people want to join I just want
to change it all up so I'm going to kind
of present to you guys
see how you guys flow with it all right
and so I got a couple of notes Here
uh this is one of the last few things
Michael did to us before he left right
besides besides [__] us yeah besides
leaving us freaked us oh he freaked us
up so good thank you so I believe that
the whole point of patreon is
for them to get closer to us like they
need to be like this close yeah you know
and then it's like you know what people
don't come here to watch like HBO
content you know what I mean like people
use patreon as a way to like hey the
exclusive best [__] is here but what I
believe is like patreon should be a
place where like all right we're not
just doing like news and entertainment
but we're actually community building
and then you have access to get closer
to it getting more connected with them
that's what a lot of people are asking
about too and we don't have that because
none of us really play with social media
like yeah Ryan's really good but but but
literally yeah we don't all have a space
where we could build this community so I
think now it's time for creating our
only friends wow I like that we're
building on only friends what does it
mean it sounds very close to another
company but it's different I don't want
to get demonetized for mentioning the
only the other one yeah all right so
we're doing only so it's tactical I like
it so so I got this i got this pitch for
you guys the first tier of our only
friends okay I want to give them access
to our private Discord because I think
that's the best way of like
finding a group that we can chat with
because I had a separate Facebook group
there's Instagram how do we bring
everybody together that are like the
core core the hottest chicks when we do
it sorry can't do it and do it sorry
yeah you want to be inclusive yeah we
want the hottest dude specifically the
hottest chicks and the greasiest dudes
oh yeah people do DM the JK account all
the time asking if we even have a
Discord so it's good that this is
happening that's awesome and also we can
all go in there to talk to everybody
yeah I need a space to clap that's all
these fans that are super bold whoa whoa
that was kind of harsh I'm smiling
though did your therapist say to say
that
you're right there
and I think the other thing is we have a
separate email where if they want to
submit articles and stuff like that
that's a big thing yeah now we can do it
all on Discord
yeah because I always tell people uh
when they submit articles because we get
so many just in the JK IG that it'd be
so easy to have it all in like one place
that one yeah and then you know because
that other people could comment on the
article and just be like yeah that one's
dope let's all do it and then you can
kind of see like what they want to talk
about too or like hey there's false
information at 38 seconds 58 seconds 77
seconds 428 seconds
and we're going to disregard all of it
yeah and we're like oh wow that's really
cool I guess we'll go with that article
that's cool fan interaction you know and
fans can ask questions on Discord like
hey what what is what what does this say
on [__] and Ryan's shirt oh he got
naked girls whatever right
and and they can ask questions just like
prompt questions when we could give them
a shout out just be like yo you know
whatever ask the question so they can
ask questions like would you rather have
your mom or your dad but like new
versions of that like your uncle or
Auntie exactly oh that's cool
cause in her second cousin yeah yeah
yeah we're still gonna have videos that
are just too spicy for YouTube so
they'll get access to that but the next
thing that I wanted to do is when we do
live recordings now there's a space
where they can watch all past recordings
if they missed it right so they're gonna
have access to that nice that's our very
first tier I I feel like that's a lot of
that's a great first a lot of stuff it's
a good tier that's just all in one tier
that's the first level get out of here
wait that's the first and I can get a
hold of it if I act now act now baby
that's but there's only five spots for
75 easy payments of what but where do
the savings get passed down
customer baby the people who don't watch
all the videos will be like why did he
sound like such a [__] [__]
[Laughter]
so here's our second level all right
it's called It's called The only homies
yeah I like that one because in every
friend group you have your acquaintances
you have your friends and you have your
homies yeah they're tighter the circle
gets tighter closer huh yeah well isn't
that what everyone says about us like
it's like we're like their friend group
yeah but are we their homies we're more
like their uncles that might be true
we're like they're an embarrassing uncle
or they have to watch boys they have to
watch it with headphones on so when we
do live streams this only homies they
can actually tune in live so as it's
happening they'll be invited they'll get
a special like so it's almost like a
live taping and it could be anything
right it could be like the lives that we
do when we go on walks it could be the
lives where you you're a studio audience
member watching us film like that kind
of thing so now we're gonna have lives
with them so we could respond to them
they're gonna be chatting with us all
that right that's dope and so they get
all of that other stuff but they also
get that interaction with us too cool
they can tune in chat while we shoot
this jkn live and those are the videos
that our only friends can watch what
happened the only friends get to watch
the live streams of us with the only
homies yeah there it is but only homies
are the the participants yeah
but okay here's the second level because
what if you want to actually come apart
and be a part of the conversation and it
will beam you in and all that that's
going to be reserved for our Only Lovers
whoa like if they want to have a sit
down and have an intimate conversation
with us oh that's our Only Lovers that's
pretty tight so that seat right there
where Steve is sitting oh no I'm
replaced that's gonna be the only lover
that we've talked to nice a real life
person or a computer screen over their
face it's gonna be a computer screen
okay yeah maybe we'll put the straw man
that was here when I had
um my Hospital complications oh that's
your specific stun double thank you but
then we can put like a screen here or
something or like a a green screen here
it'll be can can will be sitting there
and then we'll he'll hold the iPad
really good yeah we could that would be
good that way we can dehumanize can
while we also do this well he'll be just
deleting the footage at the same time
at this level two you'll be a producer
so your name will be in the credits yeah
you know at the end roll we're gonna
have an emerald we're gonna start oh
dude we're gonna be like cam girls whoa
the biggest
are gonna have like their names whatever
they want on the [__] like roll yeah
like thank you for a [__] producers
yeah you know what I mean or Only Lovers
and then if their name is like [__] you
JK like they'll be credited
exactly yeah we'll see we'll say [__]
you JK okay and here's the cool thing
it's a sweet dealer submitted by JK
sucks ass
and then so like let's say they they're
like ride or dies right like man they've
been with them they've been with us for
like three months they can request for a
personal shout out after you get
recognized you get thanked you get
sucked off are we organized enough for
this I don't know wait a personal sucker
for a personal shout out both what is it
I don't need to be organized for the
suck off but are we gonna be able to do
shout outs
not a problem that's if they've been on
here for how much time three months
three months wow
I would give it a shout out once every
three months but here's the best part of
all this is the highest level of
closeness right okay let's say they've
been dedicated with us for 12 months as
a straight lover you know we've been
doing those JK Adventures right we're
gonna invite them to be a part of that
so when we go out on these Adventures
airsofting whatever
you can get shot with airsoft we can
shoot your butt you could eat stinky
tofu
you can have a miserable time you can
shoot Ken you have welts in your body
for whatever Adventure we're doing for
the day I hope they can make it watch
it's like someone that wins and they're
from like Europe or something well maybe
they can have a redeemable pass for like
when they can make it then they can go
to that Adventure that would be cool I
mean we're still workshopping this and
I'm just pitching it to you guys
um but I kind of feel like this is a lot
of stuff that we can give and it it's
like good community building and it's
really worth hey here's an idea how
about the top donor like Whoever has
donated the most
like top of the leaderboard there is
like a name where that's the top donor
that's cool like they do
it yeah wow
you're some sort of like they need to
Dethrone that person if they want right
right right right right and we like show
visible worshiping to it
we'll burnt incense what about top
dollars like a dollar
just a sweet just to sweeten the pot a
little bit Yeah accidental donation if
you're if you're here for 12 months I
will tell you about my favorite crypto
which I keep very I keep very secret you
don't you know you don't I don't tell
people about it yeah that is something
that no and I know for a fact after 12
months his favorite crypto is still
gonna be the same same favorite well
we'll see because I uh you know we'll
see about that anyways if you guys want
to know more go ahead and click in the
description box below check out our
patreon patreon.com just kiddingnews and
go ahead click out all those tiers check
it out be our only friend only homie
Only Lover whatever you want to be only
times let's do it because this is gonna
be extremely fun
um if you're already on it right now
we're already in the Discord we're
already doing this so we have a Discord
already oh yeah
how come we weren't invited man thanks
for your support everybody thank you
guys you guys can't wait to meet all six
of you give back so hard we're gonna get
back so hard
[Music]